on les voit de plus en plus souvent dans
les restaurants et les épiceries à peine
entrer dans l'adolescence ils sont déjà
au travail Ophélie la montagne a été
embauchée ici à 12 ans elle en a
maintenant 14
ans
c'est sûr je rencontre une nouvelle
personne ça m'amène l'autonomie depuis
un an et demi elle conjugue le travail
les études et le ski de compétition
pendant l'année scolaire elle travaille
environ 10 heures par semaine
[Musique]
ses parents l'ont tout de suite appuyé à
veut gagner sa propre argent elle veut
gagner de l'autonomie
moi c'est vraiment fier son père affirme
qu'il n'y a pas eu d'impact sur ses
résultats scolaires c'est sûr que c'est
les études en premier donc on est
chanceux je pense Ophélie
une étudiante qui réussit quand même
bien à l'école
oxygène
il y a aucune demande de congé là qui
est refusé un jeune peut nous donner 9
heures en période d'examen venait me
voir et dire j'ai besoin d'étudier et on
descend les heures à 3 heures
la fromagerie Victoria compte une
vingtaine de restaurants au Québec il a
majorité de ces 165 employés sont des
étudiants
parmi eux on en compte environ 20 qui
ont entre 12 et 14 ans comme Marina Noël
qui rêve de devenir urgentologue ça
coûte vraiment
cher
à travailler pour me garder des fonds
pour faire
samedi puis le dimanche le garde pour
étudier pour faire mes devoirs j'ai vu
mes amis comment ça travailler donc je
me suis dit je pourrais commencer à
travailler moi aussi comme dans bien
d'autres entreprises les jeunes sont
devenus pratiquement indispensables
c'est ça qu'elles sont depuis nos doses
13 ans on va devoir jongler avec nos
horaires autrement ça serait peut-être
pas facile
inquiet pour la réussite scolaire des
jeunes travailleurs le gouvernement le
goût s'apprête à resserrer les règles
parmi les recommandations du Comité
consultatif du travail et de la main
d'oeuvre fixer un âge minimal de 14 ans
l'embauche et imposer une limite de 10
heures de travail du lundi au vendredi
pour un maximum de 17 heures par semaine
pendant l'année scolaire on est assez
favorable à l'établissement d'un ange
minimal de 14 ans selon le réseau
québécois pour la réussite éducative il
est impératif que les enfants de 12 et
13 ans mettent toutes leurs énergies
pour réussir leur transition du primaire
au second
est difficile pour la majorité des
jeunes puis cette jeune sur 10 vont
démontrer un des signes suivants
augmentation de l'anxiété de performance
des engagements scolaires diminution de
la motivation son ajoute le travail
par-dessus ça mais on comprend qu'on
ajoute des facteurs de risque à un ange
ou déjà ils sont déjà très sollicités
juste par le fait de vivre ce grand
changement là dans leur vie
selon les études le travail à petite
dose chez les jeunes peut être bénéfique
et favoriser notamment le développement
du sens des responsabilités mais il
comporte des risques particulièrement
au-delà de 15 heures par semaine manque
de sommeil problème de santé mentale
consommation de drogue et d'alcool sans
compter les accidents de travail les
gens qui travaillent en plus de chances
de décrocher que ceux qui travaillent
pas et ceux qui travaillent le plus
d'heures se mettent le plus à risque de
décrochage scolaire donc oui bah les
îles nombre d'or de travail c'est
également une mesure intéressante
l'industrie de la restauration se dit
d'accord pour limiter le nombre d'heures
mais s'oppose à un âge minimal il faut
pas qu'il y ait de limite d’âge parce
que c'est 12-13 ans là ont mis sur eux
pour les former puis pour être capable
de les faire évoluer au sein de
l'entreprise
Eric Tremblay embauché plusieurs jeunes
de 12 à 14 ans au cours des dernières
années dans son restaurant de La Malbaie
c'est évident que dans une région comme
Charlevoix dans la réalité de la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre qui a présentement si
on n'a pas ces jeunes là ça peut mettre
à mal certains cas de travail ces jeunes
là on va pas aller chercher à la maison
c'est eux qui se présentent souvent avec
les parents on a des discussions les
parents sont prêts à lui laisser
travailler à les faire à leur faire
faire des essais l'association des
restaurateurs du Québec réclament une
exhension dans le projet de loi qui sera
déposé pour que les moins de 14 ans
puissent continuer de travailler dans
leur secteur on a une certaine habitude
à les gérer on peut les emmener à
progresser puis nous suivent souvent ils
suivent dans le restaurant jusqu'à 15-16
ans ou plus tard jusqu'à temps qu'il
trouve un métier on est d'accord que
l'école doit demeurer la priorité de ces
jeunes là mais ça n'empêche pas qu'un
travail rémunéré peut être formateur
aussi je pense pas qu'on peut régler
notre problème de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre en faisant travailler nos
enfants selon André Mayer il y a urgence
d'agir pour prévenir les abus des
employeurs qui appellent à l'école
secondaire pour sortir un jeune de la
classe pour venir faire un remplacement
suite à une absence ou des parents qui
motivent l'absence d'un jeune parce que
l'employeur a besoin qu'il rentre
travailler parce que quelqu'un a collé
malade puis on se voyait depuis un
certain nombre d'années en trois quatre
cinq mais là on le voit dès secondaire 1
2 donc la à notre avis on a un peu perdu
le contrôle puis c'est le temps de tirer
une ligne claire
c'est ce qu'on croit aussi dans cette
organisme de Montréal Nord où l'on
propose des activités gratuites pour les
jeunes dans le quartier on sait que
certains travaillent pour aider leurs
parents financièrement une autre réalité
ou de famille aisée ne font pas ça alors
c'est généralement la pauvreté qui amène
à ça nous avons beaucoup de familles
monoparentales ici ce sont ses enfants
là pour joindre pour aider maman à 14
ans 12-13 ans tu vas dire que maman quoi
tu es supposé rêver
peu importe la décision du gouvernement
il y aura des mécontents
moi je pense que 12 ans scolaire
les gens de travailler moi je pense
qu'on va on va les faire régresser
justement dans leur développement
personnel puis dans leur autonomie en
protégeant les plus vulnérables Québec
risque de pénaliser d'autres jeunes
capables de bien concilier le travail et
les études
on vient d'entendre les deux points de
vue il y a vraiment deux points de vue
pins plus le ministre du Travail est
avec nous Jean Boulet bonsoir Monsieur
roi alors on le voit il y a des
arguments très intéressants des gens qui
vous disent ne fixez pas un âge minimal
parce que à 12-13 ans dans les
restaurants entre autres ça peut être
très formateur et les restaurateurs en
ont besoin est-ce que vous votre idée
est faite il y aura un âge minimal bah
écoutez d'abord j'ai consulté dans les
leaders patronaux que les centrales
syndicales qui sont réunis au comité
consultatif du travail et de la main
d'oeuvre ils m'ont soumis des
recommandations le 8 décembre dernier et
ils ont fait un consensus parce
qu'effectivement il y a des arguments
qui militent en faveur ou en défaveur et
ils ont recommandé de fixer un ange
minimal d'admission à l'emploi à 14 ans
puis de fixer aussi des limites du
nombre d'or quand l'enfant ou le jeune
est tenu vous allez à l'école et ça ça
respecte aussi monsieur Roy les
conventions internationales que le
Canada a déjà entériné donc 12-13 ans
pourra plus aller travailler dans un
restaurant écoutez le projet de loi sera
déposé d'ici quelques semaines il
pourrait y avoir un ange minimal
d'admission à l'emploi il pourrait y
avoir des exceptions en bas de 14 ans
c'est une des recommandations d'ailleurs
qui était présentée par le comité
consultatif est-ce que le monde la
restauration pourrait faire l'objet
d'exception
là
mais tout est possible mais ce qui est
extrêmement important c'est de redire
que la place de l'enfant est d'abord et
avant tout à l'école il faut respecter
sa santé son développement physique et
moral il faut aussi s'assurer de sa
réussite éducative donc les deux
objectifs qui doivent nous guider c'est
d'abord la sécurité et ensuite la
persévérance scolaire OK pourrait-il y
avoir des exceptions on l'a vu la
fromagerie Victoria pour ne pas la
nommer
cette jeune fille qui fait du ski de
compétition et bonne à l'école a dit moi
à 12-13 ans je suis capable en plus de
faire une dizaine d'heures est-ce que
elle pourrait continuer à le faire il
pourrait y avoir des exceptions de cette
nature là on a fait beaucoup de
consultations des acteurs de la société
civile le réseau québécois pour la
réussite éducative la Commission des
droits de la personne et des droits de
la jeunesse lors des conseillers en
ressources humaines agréé et donc on a
fait un consensus qui à mon avis
représente un bon équilibre actuellement
puis je le répète il faut absolument
mettre l'accent sur l'importance des
études d'abord le métier de l'enfant
c'est d'être un élève parce que je
montrais les statistiques que je vais
vous remontrer seconde première
secondaire deuxième secondaire ça en
effet exploser le nombre de jeunes qui
sont sur le marché du travail ça de
façon générale ça vous inquiète
ce qui m'inquiète c'est surtout le
nombre d'accidents de travail qui est en
augmentation considérable des jeunes de
11 ans 12 ans 13 ans qui se baisent des
lésions musculo-squelettiques qui
doivent supporter des changes trop
élevés qui font du travail répétitif et
c'est ça qui est important c'est devenu
un enjeu de société je comprends les
employeurs en contexte de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre mais il y a d'autres
bassins de main d'oeuvre qui sont plus
éloignés du marché de l'emploi qui
peuvent répondre aux besoins des
employeurs sans oublier l'importance de
la numérisation pour accroître leur
productivité mais il y a des employeurs
un modèle puis fromagerie Victoria
m'apparaît un modèle de respect de
l'importance ou de la priorité qu'on
doit accorder aux études de l'enfant
mais même s'ils sont un modèle encore
une fois de manière générale vous dites
un enfant de 12-13 ans avant 14 ans donc
il serait l'âge limite ne pas vraiment
sa place dans une cuisine c'est juste un
certain nombre par semaine bénéfique
pour l'estime de soi la valorisation la
confiance aussi le sens des
responsabilités mais au-delà d'un
certain nombre d'heures ce que les
études démontent c'est que ça crée de la
fatigue du stress de l'anxiété ça
affecte les résultats académiques et
éventuellement ça incite au décrochage
mais pourquoi donc ne pas
ne pas moduler le nombre d'heures avec
un nombre d'heures maximales sévère et
de pas toucher à l'âge autrement dit
quelqu'un de 12 ans âge minimal 12 ans
quelqu'un 12 ans pourra aller travailler
mais 5 6 7 8 9 10 heures maximum par
semaine il pourrait y avoir des
exceptions dans le projet de loi qui
vont permettre à l'enfant de 11 12 13
ans par exemple de travailler dans des
domaines où il y a peu de risques pour
leur santé sécurité puis leur santé
psychologique
ça peut être une colonie de vacances
dans le secteur communautaire le domaine
artistique il y a beaucoup mais pas la
restauration dans votre belle non je me
prononce pour là-dessus là je comprends
votre question qui est hypothétique on
verra quand le nom de la restauration
veut savoir est-ce qu'ils vont devoir
remplacer tout ce personnel là ben il y
a beaucoup de d'accidents de travail qui
sont survenu dans ce type
d'environnement de travail là puis c'est
important de redire l'importance
d'identifier les risques pour la santé
tant physique que psychologique des
jeunes très bien donc déposer quand le
projet de loi ben d'ici quelques
semaines il reste quelques étapes à
franchir et ça devrait normalement d'ici
trois quatre semaines avec déposé au
Parlement Québec et des battu un prêt
monsieur boulet merci beaucoup merci
Monsieur au revoir au revoir au revoir